[Musique]
bonjour yan monplaisir membres des
républicains de martinique candidat à la
législative dans le nord il vous est là
avec nous ce matin pour évoquer ces
derniers épisodes de l'actualité
politique du moment et parmi ces
épisodes
il ya cette prise de position d'alfred
marie jeanne a barré la route à marine
le pen
dans un communiqué paris la nuit
dernière plutôt surprenant de la part
d'un homme de parti le minime
n'ayant jamais pris position pour la
présidentielle française on pensé quoi
il ya donc les dix ans que les
circonstances l'imposent ou l'imposait
et que l frais de marie-jeanne est un
homme de responsabilité qu'il le prouve
encore une fois c'est l'urgence de
situation oui c'est ce qui s'est passé
est évident le fait travailler avec des
formations comme la vôtre une évolution
de comportement de positionnement qui
viendra écornée ou peut être relever
l'image de cet homme droit doubout tu
dois te doutes qu'il a toujours montré
je pense qu'on peut à la fois être droit
debout je le prouve moi même et en même
temps avoir le sens des réalités du
pragmatisme qu'impose des situations les
république perd les républicains
maintenant ils n'ont plaisir votre
famille se déchire les sarkozystes vous
en faites partie veulent prendre les
rênes du mouvement françois baroin
mènerait la campagne laurent pour qui
elle se prendrait la présidence eric
woerth serait chargée de réécrire le
programme c'est du passage en force
je ne sais pas ce que c'est je pense que
c'est simplement la vie politique dans
la vie politique il ya des moments qui
impose que l'on réagisse que l'on prenne
des positions c'est ce qu'ils font et en
facial et des jupes et east qui réclame
notamment une position claire sur la
ligne adoptée ou le second tour face à
marine le pen
c'est à dire une consigne claire de vote
fer batte le pen sans appeler à voter
macron c'est pas peu fier c'est un signe
très clair la position du des
républicains est très claire il faut
barrer la route à marine le pen
mais il faut dire tout simplement qu'il
faut voter pour l'adversaire ce qu'on
retrouve battre quelqu'un oui on vote on
appelle à voter pour
macron c'est clair ah bah écoute est
vrai les républicains jouent en gros
avec les législatives c'est votre
dernière carte à abattre ces élections
du mois de juin les républicains jouent
gros vous savez moi je suis quelqu'un
d'engagement et de loyauté
j'ai une j'appartiens à une famille
politique je n'ai pas souhaité avoir
l'investiture des républicains parce que
je veux en même temps concilier là
exigence de liberté et de liberté de
l'art postal l'enfance ont géré mon
plaisir
non ce n'est pas un passage en force
c'est une cohérence dans ma démarche
alors les républicains ils vont et je
suis avec eux dans ce combat pour
essayer de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une majorité de républicains l'assemblée
nationale mais s'il n'y avait pas une
majorité de républicains s'imposerait de
fait la nécessité d'une alliance pour
diriger la france en tout cas moi je ne
serai pas de ceux qui vont jouer la
politique du pire
je l'éprouvé ici à la martinique quand
il s'est agi de faire un choix
déterminant pour la martinique
je l'avais d'abord fait à l'époque avec
guy lordinot j'avais été très précurseur
je les fais à nouveau plus récemment
avec alfred marie-jeanne avec le mime et
nous avons eu permis cette victoire 16 à
9 heures d'art d'istria de montplaisir
je suis un homme de mon temps c'est ce
que je pense je pense simplement que
quand vous regardez le résultat du
scooter la martinique s'exprime ici une
vraie souffrance
effectivement le vote de deux pour
marine le pen interpelle et vous
remarquerez que le vote pour marine le
pen est un peu plus marquée dans les
régions où il ya un vrai problème
économique où il n'y a pas d'emploi où
les gens souffrent plus qu'ailleurs
ah ça c'est le candidat qui a un copain
qui s'exprime là vous parlez du de
recruter moi je suis un candidat je
dirais depuis que je suis engagé en
politique je suis un candidat permanent
on ne peut pas faire de la politique par
intermittence donc moi je dis ce que je
constate et j'explique pourquoi et
comment je m'engage alors qu'est-ce
qu'il s'agit de faire pour le mois de
juin la famille l'est républicain veut
peser au bien être beaucoup plus qu'une
simple variable d'ajustement au sein
d'an marche ou avec en marche à côté
dans marche des manuels macron ce que je
souhaite ya eu il y a eu une sanction
des partis politiques traditionnels le
parti socialiste a été éjecté carrément
le parti républicain aux saisons en
prison ou en raison des chances et aussi
en raison non pas éjecter parce que
regarder le résultat le résultat n'est
pas ridicule mais mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a eu un tassement et ce tassement il
résulte de ce rejet est effectivement
des grands partis traditionnels
les gens disent vous nous
veut du concret on veut des résultats
vous n'apportez pas de résultats et puis
ensuite nous n'avions pas un candidat je
l'avais indiqué j'avais souhaité qu'il
se retire très vite après je lui ai
apporté mon soutien parce que
j'appartiens à une famille politique et
qu'il faut être responsable mais nous
n'avions pas le meilleur candidat même
s'il a beaucoup de qualités françois
fillon mais il a été plombé par une
véritable cabale montée sans doute par
le président de la république pour ces
législatives les républicains qu'est ce
qu'ils devraient faire
adoucir le projet de françois fillon par
rapport à ce qu'ils avaient proposées
pour les présidentielles les
républicains doivent être ce qu'ils sont
c'est à dire une force politique majeure
au sein de la république
ils doivent continuer à affirmer et à
renforcer les valeurs qui sont les leurs
parmi ces valeurs nous ne partageons pas
de points communs avec marine le pen et
donc nous l'exprimons de manière très
claire
et puis nous voulons rassembler les
français mais moi je je souhaite porter
un projet pour la martinique
c'est pour cela que il me faut avoir
deux voulaient tourner cette page de la
présidentielle déjà plus même plus qu'on
parle des républicains mais passionné
par ce que j'espère mais péter j'étais
noah était quand même
non je n'en manque je suis je tu as tu
alors que non non non non non non rires
et le futur je me suis passionné je ne
suis pas gêné par le score de françois
fillon il est en recul mais je vous
rappelle que hollande ne faisait 59% des
voix et qu'aujourd'hui les socialistes
avec le soutien du ppm et notamment de
de serge letchimy n'ont fait que 9% à la
martinique donc moi je suis très à
l'aise dans ce résultat très très à
l'aise je constate simplement qu'ils que
c'est mélenchon qui a été mis en tête à
la martinique que que marine le pen a
fait une percée donc que les
martiniquais on te crie à pousser et moi
je pousse ce cri avec eux je veux être
là le porte parole des martiniquais je
veux dire aux gouvernements quels qu'ils
soient à la majorité quelle qu'elle soit
je veux le dire avec force détermination
et conviction que ça ne peut plus durer
et que l'outre-mer ne peut pas être
simplement le gadget de la république
que l'outre-mer à sa place au sein de la
république je le jure le dit jeudi en
2012 vous avez raison que je le dis
depuis longtemps gelé 10 en 2012 c'était
même le thème central de ma campagne et
j'expliquais déjà en 2012 que ce que je
voulais c'était non pas que l'on sorte
de cette république mais que nous ayons
toute notre place au sein de ses
tribunes alors la marque je suis un
républicain si vous me permettez est
donc ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on ne
peut pas laisser ces populations
d'outre-mer dans la situation où elles
sont c'est à dire une situation de
marginalisation avec des jeunes qui
quittent leur pays quand quand des
jeunes les pays auxquels ils sont
attachés
parce que nous aimons nos pays près et
c'est un déchirement pour nous et il
sait qu'il ya un problème de fond ce
problème de fond c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
développement économique qui repose sur
notre implication
ce qu'on appelle le développement
endogène c'est à dire que les la
structure du modèle économique dans
lequel nous sommes les figues résulte du
modèle politique vous permettait de
déterminer que cette structure là et est
pénalisante et qu'elle ne permet pas le
développement continu et sauf que vous
venez de le dire
jean luc mélenchon arrive en tête en
martinique via la percée de marine le
pen
tout simplement parce que les
martiniquais en ont peut être assez
d'entendre des gens qui comme vous mais
ça fait tellement de choses depuis un
certain temps mais je les aime et qu'ils
n'obtiennent pas de résultat vous avez
raison vous avez raison c'est mon
plaisir c'est la recette ferez mieux
crise et la saison en 2012 auparavant
c'est parce que en 2012 les martiniquais
n'ont pas suffisamment entendue mais je
pense qu'ils n'entendront cette fois ci
ils m'en ont déjà donné l'illustration
récemment vous savez que on nous donnait
5 % d'espérance monsieur marage aux 10
mm 3 % au moment des élections à la
collectivité territoriale nous avons
terminé à 15%
parce que j'ai été entendu et c'est là
et c'est parce que j'ai été entendu
c'est là ce que j'ai été entendu et que
nous avons fait une alliance avec alfred
marie-jeanne que nous avons pu changer
ce qui semblait inéluctable à la
martinique c'est à dire l'élection le
métier en place du ppm et bien ils
pouvaient certes victoire là est ce donc
forcément il ya le plaisir des jeunes
hommes trop averti pour faire comme s'il
n'y a pas eu ce premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle mais bien sûr
c'est pour ça que j'en tiens compte mais
c'est sur ça que par derrière votre élan
effréné là mais pas du tout non au
contraire
au contraire le nom je suis monsieur
pamphile par exemple qui représente ici
monsieur macron je l'avais candidat à
vie qui est candidat dans la
circonscription
eh bien je l'avais oublié en 2 10
il ya quelques années de cela quand
j'avais fait de l'alliance avec guy
lordinot et bien dany daniel chow mais
il lui était venu nous apporter leur
soutien donc il n'ya pas il faut que le
martiniquais à certains moments puis se
rassembler gg j'ai porté ce
rassemblement avec une certaine
incompréhension au début même si
aujourd'hui tout le monde reconnaît que
j'ai eu raison de le faire
j'ai porté cette volonté de
rassemblement il y avait déjà cédé
cordiale donc bientôt droit de lyon
gagne vous comprenez bien qu'aujourd'hui
je suis porteur de cet espoir ce que ce
que je veux pour la martinique
c'est précisément ce que les
martiniquais veulent c'est à dire sortir
des clivages
quand l'intérêt de la martinique est à
l'enjeu et ne plus voir c'est que
l'intérêt de l'artiste et du bergsonisme
ce que vous faites là et bien gt gt sans
doute précurseur et j'étais sans doute
avant lui dans cette démarche je vais
vous voyez qu'il ment bouenza
extraordinaire je n'ai pas de problème
merci d'avoir avec tôt ce matin il ya
nos plaisirs rappelle que vous êtes
membre des républicains est candidat si
on n'a pas compris après ce moteur ne
comprendra aiguë et demande à la
législative dans le nord merci mr
journée merci de cette invitation
[Musique]